first this about two dozen reporters
from the US Britain China and Russia
arrived overnight in North Korea to
witness the plan dismantling of the
country's nuclear test site CBS News is
the only u.s. broadcast network in that
group
the reporters expect to travel tomorrow
from one Sun up into the mountains for
the ceremony at the remote site this
morning North Korea is lashing out at
the u.s. and South Korea over joint
military drills North Korea's state
media says dialogue and saber-rattling
can never go together and will chill the
atmosphere before the planned u.s. north
korean summit Ben Tracy arrived in North
Korea just hours ago and filed this
report so we've just landed here in now
once on North Korea this is on the
country's East Coast and as you can see
back over here this is a massive and
modern Airport they've spent a lot of
money here because they're trying to
turn this part of North Korea
an international tourist
the North Koreans built this Airport a
couple of years ago but it's really
never been used so all of this is being
done for our arrival the people who are
working here the magazine's over here
the North Korean flags that they're
selling once we leave we assume most of
us will be shut down now the reason
we're here of course is to witness North
Korea shutting down its main nuclear
testing facility this is where the North
has conducted all six of its nuclear
tests in recent years now this site is
in a very remote and mountainous part of
North Korea and this is 11 hours on a
train four hours on a bus and then an
hour long hike to the site itself now in
addition to journalists were told that
North Korea has not invited any outside
experts in to witness what they claim is
the closure of this site for CBS this
morning Ben Tracy in North Korea